mais toi va danser dans la ronde de
l'espoir voici océane à 18 ans elle
vient de remporter samedi soir son
ticket pour la finale du tremplin des
voix dans la catégorie auteur
compositeur interprète avec sa chanson
de l'espoir je reçois le coup téléphone
les échanges en anglais en fait parce
que je m'y attendais vraiment pas je
dirais qu'en fait ça ces avantages
d'être sur zoom parce que on est quand
même on a quand même le confort d'être
chez soi même s'il ya toujours le stress
de est ce que mon micro va bien marcher
est ce que la connexion va rester prévu
normalement à magny les hameaux et
montigny le bretonneux cette année kobe
19 oblige les auditions ne se font pas
en présentiel
mais en ligne pour cette première
audition 30 participants qui passe par
plusieurs étapes
on a essayé la de reproduire assez
fidèlement ce qui se passe en physique
c'est à dire qu'effectivement ils sont
en plusieurs groupes répartis en
plusieurs groupes et il ya des parts
groupe de passage il ya des groupes qui
vont en coaching donc scène des groupes
qui vont en coaching vocal etc etc
donc c'est exactement le même
fonctionnement la pédagogie et
l'accompagnement sont les maîtres mots
de ce concours de chant
les coaches donne des astuces aux
artistes et leur permettent de se
produire dans un cadre bienveillant
derrière l' avantage du tremplin des
voix c'est qu'on a et on a beaucoup de
partenaires qui leur offre énormément de
prestations comme des tournages de clips
ou alors tout simplement des producteurs
qui sont en relation avec nous des
directeurs de labels et donc ça leur
ouvre vraiment des portes
deux autres auditions france sont
prévues en ligne le 21 et 28 novembre
avec trente participants pour les deux
sessions et les auditions à la réunion
le 12 décembre en physique la finale
composée de quinze à vingt candidats
sera organisée le 30 janvier à magny les
hameaux